تنتظر جدران هذه الغرفه ساكنها منذ سنوات
لكنه لن يعود فالوليد الغريبي عاد لاسرته
بعد سنوات اغتراب بحثا عن العلم في
الولايات المتحده جثه هامده جريمه قتل
الوليد قبل انهاء اجراءات تخرجه هزت مجتمع
المبتعثين السعوديين في الولايات المتحده
لكن هنا في منزل اسرته كانت صدمتها مزلزله
[موسيقى]
والله تلقيت في جاني ايميل من شرطه
الفلادلفيا وكانت صراحه ايميل
يعني اسوا ايميل مر عليه في حياتي الحقيقه
وفحوى الايميل انه
الرجاء الاتصال على قسم
ان قسم القتل
بشان الوليد الغريبي
رجعت الاتصال على المحقق فلان والرقم وفي
ارقام
قراته
يعني ما استوعب يعني
الدكتور عبد الله الذي اصطحب الوليده مع
بقيه افراد الاسره متنقلا بين استراليا
والولايات المتحده اثناء عمله الدبلوماسي
في الملحقات السعوديه
يتذكر طموح ولده الفقيد في البحث عن عمل
في السعوديه بمجرد الانتهاء من دراسته
يبدو ان طلبه المساعده وطلع به لانه وقت
خروجها الان
وبعدين قالوا لنا الشرطه انه منزله شنطتها
في السياره وجاهزه
من طيابته ثقته
وفي نفس الوقت يبغى يتخلص منها ما صدق على
نفس الطلاء الحمد لله
مو انه حاسب خطر منها ابدا لو حسب خطر ما
راح يطلع بس يعني تقربها
في الطريق غرفتها
بالحمام
بدات عمليته وضربته ودفعته في الحمام
وكملت العمليه
كانت عمليه بشعه وتاكدت انه انت وبعدين
قفلت عليه الحمام قفلت الحمام وطلعت
هي راحت وراحت الغرفه بس وش اللي راح اللي
صار الاول ما ندري يعني لانه في دم هنا
وهنا هيثم شقيق الوليد لم تمنعه اعاقته
السمعيه عن فهم تفاصيل الحادثه ومواساه
والده
صدمه دفعته لالغاء خطط لاستكمال دراسته
الجامعيه في الخارج اسره الوليد لن تعود
للولايات المتحده مجددا لكن والده المكلوم
ينوي التوجه لهناك لحضور محاكمه المتهمه
بقتل نجله وكله امل في حكم قضائي عادل من
الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه